makers of documentaries are not allow
the luxury of fiction or fancy they are
the only people in the film industry who
have to deal in the truth
they are very lonely group generally
dedicated to a cause we are about to
provide one of them with a cause for
celebration the nominees for the best
achievement in documentary features are
high schools a realistic glimpse of high
school life inside and outside the
classroom Charles Guggenheim and Nancy
schloss producers in the name of the
people The Odyssey of four American
filmmakers in rebel-held areas of El
Salvador
Alex W Dressler and Frank Christopher
producers
Malena a complex portrait of the
incomparable Marlena Dietrich Corral
durka and Zev Braun producers streetwise
a chronicle of homeless and runaway
teenagers Cheryl McCall producer the
times of Harvey Milk a film about
American values in conflict Robert
Epstein and Richard sneakin producers
and the winner is the times of Harvey
Milk
for the thrill Richard and I would like
to thank our wonderful crew particularly
Deborah Hoffman mark isham Harvey
Fierstein Greg Bex Tim O'Shea and
Francis Reid personally I would like to
thank my partner in life John Wright for
all the support during the six years it
took to get this film made and finally a
simple thank you to Harvey Milk for
reminding us that it's possible to live
life with a sense of social
responsibility and a sense of humor I
would like to thank the all the many
many people who supported the film the
volunteers donors institutional support
our distributor TC films and I would
like to also thank Harvey Milk for his
courage for his pride and being gay and
for his hope that one day we will all
live together in a world of mutual
respect thank you
you